Democrats prepared to declare the 2020
election illegitimate a terrorist attack
strains us-saudi relations and the media
take nikki Haley wildly out of context
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the bench Bureau show is sponsored
by expressvpn stand up for your digital
rights visit expressive VPN comm slash
Ben well I hope you had a wonderful
weekend we're back here on a Monday and
that means it's impeachment time man
it's time for some impeachment talk so
where are we in impeachment gate 2019
well the Democrats are apparently
planning to have this vote maybe before
Christmas they're not talking about
having this impeachment vote as early as
this week and they are rushing this
thing through today's impeachment
hearings at the Senate Judiciary
Committee House Judiciary Committee
rather they feature a bevy of democratic
lawyers because that's just what you
need I'm very convinced now that I know
a bunch of Democratic partisan hacks
like Barry Burke are speaking this has
totally changed my opinion of everything
Barry Burke is a longtime Democratic
partisan he's written a bunch for the
Brookings Institute he suggested that
Trump was guilty of collusion with
regard to Russia he suggested that Trump
was guilty of obstruction with regard to
the Muller investigation he was working
for the House Judiciary Committee as
early as February actually left his law
firm to work for the House Judiciary
Committee in February now you may be
asking yourself well why was he working
for the House Judiciary Committee in
February when the Ukraine stuff only
began to happen in like May and June and
the answer is because Barry Burke has
been Pro impeachment for a very long
time but now we are supposed to take it
with the utmost seriousness when the
Democrats call forth people who have
been for impeachment for years to say
that actually they discovered an
impeachable offense I mean it's like
amazing
unbelievably enough Barry Burke who
really has been in favor of impeachment
for years believes that the president
should be impeached based on the Ukraine
stuff so here's Barry Borough Council
for the House Democrats testifying what
House Democrats want to hear which is
the House Democrats should impeach
President Trump all the constitutional
experts who testified recognize that
obstructing an investigation is an
impeachable offense but here the offense
we're talking about that's being
interfered or obstructed with is
interfering with this very election
that's coming up and I submit to you
given what happened the Department of
Justice investigation given what's
happening here if in fact President
Trump can get away with
what he did again our imagination is the
only limit to what president trout may
do next or what a future president may
do next to try to abuse his or her power
to serve his own personal interest over
the nation's interest your imagination
is the only limit Wow I've got pretty
wild imagination as it turns out what
would it be considered abuse of power
for president say said directly to the
Russian government that he would grant
them extra flexibility on foreign policy
should they be nice to him before the
election would that would that be an
abuse of power per se you know like just
before an election like Barack Obama did
in 2012 how about like if Bill Clinton
we're taking money from Chinese cutouts
back in the 1996 election and
simultaneously declassifying nuclear
secrets would that would that be a
problem again it turns out that the
presidency has a long history of
manipulation with regard to politics but
why are we supposed to take Barry Brooks
seriously the answer is because the
media want you to take Barry Burke
seriously but there's something that's
deeper that's going on with regard to
the House Democrats impeachment effort
and it really has very little to do with
the offenses supposedly committed by
Trump with regard to Ukraine and again
none of this is defense of firms
activity in Ukraine other than to say
this is not warranting of impeachment
the Democrats wildly overplayed their
hand here they should have gone for
center if they've gone for censure they
probably could have peeled off a few
Republicans to vote in favor of
censoring Trump but they went from
Pietschmann and that makes the
Republican case very easy which is you
don't have the necessary goods on
president Trump for impeachment but it
really isn't about that it's about
something else and something that
actually is quite dangerous for the
Republic not just misusing impeachment
which again I'm not super bothered by
parties misusing impeachment impeachment
was always a political power I'm much
more bothered by something else a real
danger I think to the Republican it
doesn't come from presidential abuse of
power that's always been a danger it's
something that's that's a little
different this time
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about how you keep your
house safe so the fact is that I am
deeply worried about security all the
time so is my wife always deeply worried
about security not just because we
happen to be somewhat public but also
because we're just paranoid about
security we'll make sure that our house
is safe well the way that we keep our
house safe is we rely on ring and ring
is great especially during holiday
season because there's people who ring
your doorbell and you don't know whether
it's somebody from FedEx or whether it's
somebody who's ring your door
to see whether your humps they can break
into your house well ring allows you to
actually see who is at the door before
you open the door it allows you to and
allows you to monitor that from
thousands of miles away or even have to
be home in order to do that ring helps
you stay connected to your home from
anywhere so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you get
an alert and you're able to see here and
speak to the person at your door all
from your phone if you're on the go that
season whether it's across town or
across the country you can check in
anytime for some much-needed holiday
peace of mind you can also monitor ring
will set up a ring of security around
your house and you can actually monitor
all the areas of your house outside it
really is fantastic as a listener you
have a special holiday offer on a ring
welcome kit available right now with a
ring video doorbell - and a chime Pro
the ring welcome kit has everything you
need to keep an eye on home no matter
what this holiday season brings with
ring you are always at home just go to
ring comm /ban again that's ring.com
/ban additional terms may apply ring
comm /pret a fire line it's keep my kids
safe
you can definitely rely let's keep your
family safe - I wouldn't I don't read
that ad lightly ring calm /ban for the
holiday deal go check it out right now
okay so why are the Democrats doing all
of this because they're setting up an
argument that's gonna be made about 2020
that they also made about 2016 we have
now had four elections in the past 20
years or so in which Republicans have
won the presidency I Redbush mm mm for
Donald Trump 2016 and maybe Donald Trump
2020 I've done 201 in 2020 now one of
those elections have Democrats deem
legitimate hit 2004 they say was
illegitimate because Bush was not a
legitimately elected in 2000 they say
that Al Gore was elected in 2000 cuz
Gore won the popular vote despite the
fact that Gore did not actually win the
vote in Florida and they tried to
manipulate as much as they could they
tried to count certain ballots in on
counts other ballots in order to achieve
their desired result but bottom line is
Bush won that election
hey Democrats never accepted that he won
that election which means that
everything that he did in terms of
shaping the Supreme Court afterward is
illegitimate
according to Democrats 2004 because 2000
according to Democrats was illegitimate
is also illegitimate 2016 according to
Democrats is illegitimate not just
because Trump lost the popular vote but
because of quote-unquote Russian
interference doesn't matter by the way
that they still have not shown how that
Russian interference swung the election
to trump right we keep that this is
always the dot that's never connected
it's a
just not connected Democrats will say
things like well the Russians were
involved in the 22 2016 election and
that shifted the election I need the
evidence that it shifted the election I
know they were trying to manipulate but
do you really believe that a few
Facebook memes shifted the election in
Michigan Wisconsin and Pennsylvania is
that truly what you believe because as
someone who is one of the my personal
facebook page is one of most highly
trafficked Facebook pages on Facebook
and I can tell you the statistics that
were shown by the Senate Intelligence
Committee about the reach and power of
Russian posts on Facebook it was minimal
really minimal I mean when people say oh
that's vast Russian campaign cavey vast
Russia the only case that you can make
that the Russians really impact in the
2016 election is that the Russians were
working with WikiLeaks and they were
sending out those DNC emails that at
least is a fair case because he shifted
the nature of the election but again if
that had not come from the Russians then
it would've made a difference and also
is that Russia manipulation or WikiLeaks
manipulate even if it's Russian
manipulation let's assume that's Russian
manipulation that's not Trump Russia
collusion number one and number two the
other element of the Russian
manipulation the Democrats are
constantly talking about is the Facebook
post with all of that so again the best
case that the Russians manipulated the
2016 election has to do with the release
of those DNC emails where John Podesta
was fished and then all of those emails
were released but you'd have to show
that in the absence of the release of
those DNC emails that the Democrats
still don't lose that election because
it turns out that the bigger issue was
not what was in those DNC emails which
again was part of the campaign but
certainly not the entirety of the
campaign the biggest issue in the 2016
election was that Hillary Clinton had
taken 33,000 class emails and put them
on her private home brew server in her
bathroom and then they disappeared and
then she bleached bit the thing right
that was a bigger issue that's what
Trump really honed in on so yeah it
caused some chaos that John Podesta was
emailing mean things about Bernie
Sanders and such but did that shape the
entire outcome of the election hard to
say it's very difficult to say that a
single factor in isolation shifted the
nature of the election it certainly
wasn't the Facebook manipulation that
the Russians were engaged in that much I
can certainly say okay with all of that
said the Democrats refused to accept the
results of the 2016 election they see it
as completely illegitimate they believe
that Hillary Clinton was the elected
president and we've seen the Democrats
extend this line of thought to the gorge
governor's race for example where Stacey
Abrams lost by
50,000 votes hey you can say that that's
a close election
it is percentage-wise it is not in terms
of absolute vote Stacey Abrams lost by a
fairly large margin in the absolute vote
in Georgia Democrats still claim that
Stacey Abrams was the fairly elected
governor of Georgia so now moving
forward to 2020 Democrats are attempting
to do with this impeachment effort is
set up an argument that if Donald Trump
is elected in 2020 it's because of
Ukraine manipulation that if we're not
for Trump interfering in Ukraine and
trying to militarize American military
aids Ukraine or to get dirt on Joe Biden
that Trump wouldn't have won the 2020
election they're setting this thing up
in advance this is why they say it's
urgent to get Trump out now they say if
we don't get Trump out now then Trump
will manipulate 2020 just the way he
manipulated 2016 well you cannot have a
functional republic when people do not
accept the results of elections this
used to be a Democrat talking point they
said this in 2015 2016 about Trump
they said Trump's never going to accept
the results of the 2016 election and
he's just gonna agitate from the outside
and then we're not gonna be able to have
a republic because the truth is what
holds our republic together the only
Apple them had a piece like this over
the Atlantic making this argument it
what holds Republic together is your
feeling that the the pain that you for
the pain that you experienced staying in
the Republic is less egregious than the
pain that you would experience leaving
the Republic in other words you have to
feel as though even if you lost the
election number one it's not a threat to
your very way of life and number two you
have to feel like the election was
legitimate those two factors have to be
there well Democrats are tearing away
both of those factors right now they're
saying that Trump is not only a threat
to your way of life he's an incipient
Hitler right this guy is going to fight
your imagination is the only limit on
the boundaries of what President Trump
will do to violate the American compact
and number two his election is
illegitimate right they're setting this
thing up in advance and the second I'm
going to show you Jerry Nadler Jerry
Nadler saying this openly I mean saying
openly that if Donald Trump is not
impeached that he will cheat and that
the election will be will be skewed and
that nobody should accept it and we're
living a very dangerous this is
dangerous stuff
it is and by the way it was dangerous if
Trump had not accepted the results of
the 2016 election if Hillary Clinton won
it would be dangerous if in 2020 a
Democrat were to win and and Donald
Trump were to sit outside and say this
election was not fair and I don't accept
there's
of the election that's dangerous one
good thing that Al Gore did here in
short-lived fashion but the one good
thing that Al Gore did is after he lost
that election he said okay george w bush
as president to the united states now
that was a good thing that Al Gore did
and a worthwhile thing that Al Gore did
if we are now coming to the point where
Democrats refuse to accept the results
of elections they lose we got a problem
and if Republicans do the same thing we
don't have a republic anymore
we just have people clubbing each other
over the head I'll get some more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about a great holiday gift so if there's
a man in your life then you should be
looking at Omaha Steaks as a gift yeah I
keep kosher if I did not let me tell you
the number one gift item on my agenda
would be Omaha Steaks why listen to this
deal okay here's what you get for $69.99
the favorite gift package when you go to
Omaha Steaks calm and enter coach
Shapiro in the search bar for $69.99 get
four six ounce bacon-wrapped filet
mignons
for premium pork chops for Omaha Steaks
burgers for potatoes au gratin for
caramel apple tartlets and Omaha Steaks
signature seasoning packet plus only for
my listeners a free six piece cutlery
set and cutting board I mean and let me
tell you I've heard from so many people
who have gotten Omaha Steaks these are
like the best steaks on the market all
this delicious food plus the free
cutlery set they'll enjoy for years to
come for $69.99 so if there's a grill
master in your family my entire home
ahaa steaks is the place to go omaha
steaks are the most tender the most
flavorful and you can only get steaks of
this quality from Omaha Steaks America's
original butcher again order now and get
the favorite gift package plus free six
piece cutlery set and cutting board just
$69.99 just go to Omaha Steaks com type
Shapiro's
in the search bar don't wait if you want
to take advantage of the offer and get
your gift there before the holidays are
over order the favorite gift package
today again Omaha Steaks com type of
Shapiro's into the search bar go check
them out I mean that's an awesome gift
go check that out right now
okay so Jerry Nadler who is the chairman
of the House Judiciary Committee who
comes out over the weekend he's on Chuck
Todd and he says that if Trump isn't
impeached the twenty20 election may not
be fair and so the corollary would be so
we may not actually respect the results
here's your enamel or we also have faced
with a very direct threat that this
president put himself repeatedly above
the interests of country and poses a
threat to the integrity of the next
election
that's not
something we were talking about 20 years
ago he poses a threat to the integrity
of the next election if he's allowed to
continue to do what he's doing okay that
right there is a pre-emptive claim by
Jerry Nadler than whatever happens in
the next election for Republicans wins
it's corrupt that's supremely disturbing
it should be a stir upsetting to
everybody again this was Hillary one of
Hillary Clinton's big pitches in 2016
now she's wandering around the woods of
Chappaqua explaining that she's the
actual president of the United States we
have not had according to the Democrats
a legitimately elected Republican
president in this country since 1988
according to Democrats his I was four
years old we have not had a legitimately
elected republican president in this
country since I was a four-year-old
child according to the Democrats and
that is because again Bush was a
legitimate and now Trump is a legitimate
and then Democrats wonder why
Republicans look at them they say okay
well we don't trust you with power why
would we trust you with power you think
every time people dismiss your concerns
or your political concerns every time
you think that people overrule you and
think that you're wrong but that is
because the American people are not
actually overruling you and thinking you
are wrong and according to Democrats
Democrats have never been wrong the
American people have just been have just
been screwed in some way by the
electoral system it's why you see
Elizabeth Warren running around saying
the electoral college is unfair it's why
I see the Democrats running around for
the past several years saying the United
States Senate should be reconstituted
according to population which of course
defeats the purpose of the United States
Senate the Democrats at for all the talk
about Trump is a threat to the system
Trump has not actually threatened the
system Trump like really what is the
giant threat to the system that Donald
Trump has provided so far Donald Trump
has done less with executive orders that
than Barack Obama did he hasn't been
droning American citizens overseas the
way the Barack Obama was so far as I'm
aware he's continued to drone war but
not nearly at the same rate that Barack
Obama was he certainly didn't militarize
the IRS the way that Obama's IRS was
militarized hidden militarize his HHS
the way the Barack Obama militarized his
HHS so where is it where is the threat
to the press where's the threat to the
press he hasn't been going after members
of the press and trying to jail them and
phone tapped them whether Barack Obama's
DOJ was so we're
exactly is the threat the threat
according to the Democrats is in Trump's
personal behavior that Trump act
transactionally with regards to the
presidency and again I don't think that
there is untruth and I think a lot more
president I think he's just more obvious
about it than other presidents I think
Barack Obama did too I think Obama was
just elegant and subtle in a way that
Donald Trump is not I mean Donald Trump
is a direct rebuttal to the subtlety and
elegance of Barack Obama in a variety of
ways for both good and bad but with that
said if you're talking about threats to
the system Democrats are openly calling
for the overthrow of the electoral
college they want the reconstitution of
the United States Senate and they're
saying that if Donald Trump wins in 2020
it is fundamentally illegitimate at the
outset from the beginning it is
fundamentally illegitimate and it's not
just Jerry Nadler right Al Green the
representor from New York who's been
trying to impeach Trump since literally
the first day that Trump was in office
Al Green says that Trump has to be
thrown out of office not because Donald
Trump is has committed some sort of
impeachable crime but because Donald
Trump is a bad man who represents the
history of slavery in America if you
believe that Donald Trump is a
representative of slavery in the United
States and also that if he wins election
it's fundamentally illegitimate how do
you live in a country with people who
believe that every election is stolen
from them I don't know I don't know how
that's gonna work and by the way I'm
scared of that on the other side too I
am you know that the fact is that if
Donald Trump loses and if Donald Trump
thing goes out and he says this election
was stolen from me for whatever reason
right he can complain about the media
that's fair the media hate him he can
complain about the fact that the
Democrats lie about him routinely we'll
get to that in a second they do okay but
if Trump loses in 2020 and then he comes
back the next day and he says actually I
didn't lose actually I won and people
believe him we got a problem you have to
accept the results of elections but
Democrats never have and this is the
great hypocrisy of Democrats they were
blaming Trump for this preemptively and
they have yet to accept the result of an
election since again for 20 years they
keep saying that Republicans who are
elected are not actually elected
meanwhile you have actual manipulated
elections like Norm Coleman versus Al
Franken in the state of Minnesota where
votes are magically discovered after the
final count is in or the Dino Rossi race
in in Washington State a few years back
where Democrats suddenly discovers votes
that puts the demo
right over the top like those are actual
questionable elections but I'm sorry
2016 as far as the actual vote count was
not a questionable election and Donald
Trump did not coordinate with the
Russians as the Imola report found and
yet we are still told he's illegitimate
and now the Democrats are playing up
that Trump is illegitimate going into
2020 and no matter what happens he will
be illegitimate even if he wins also he
happens to be a vicious slave slit
pro-slavery racist according to Al Green
so things are going well in the country
I do believe ma'am
that we have to deal with the original
sin we have to deal with slavery slavery
was the thing that put all of what
President Trump has done lately into
motion
but until we deal with the issue of
invidious discrimination as a relates to
LGBTQ community the anti-semitism the
racism the Islamophobia the transphobia
and also the misogyny that he has
exemplified I don't think our work is
done okay what when the hell does that
have to do with impeachment exactly
remember the question before that was an
impeachment question what does that have
to do with him Beach Minh and by the way
again Nancy Pelosi is engaged in this
sort of language so here's what we've
learned from the Democrats if Donald
Trump is is reelected or if he is not
impeached the civilization itself is at
stake Nancy Pelosi says this is
civilization is at stake also if he is
elected it's a legitimate I mean I can't
think much of more of a recipe for chaos
and conflict than that here's Nancy
Pelosi saying American civilization is
at stake if Donald Trump is not
impeached over Ukraine uh-huh sure and
what is America our values of values of
what we care about is a nation a model a
beacon of hope to the world and he did
that he values that so again we don't
agonize we organize and we do so in a
way that again is unifying for a country
it is absolutely imperative civilization
as we know it today is at stake in the
next election civilization is at stake
in the next election if Donald Trump
wins civilization is over its oh by the
way I didn't like this language when
Republicans used it about Hillary
Clinton in 2016
go back and
since my podcasts you can hear it you
know the idea that America was over if
Hillary Clinton won yes America would
have been worse if Hillary Clinton won
that if Donald Trump won but with
civilization over were you gonna go home
and sell your house and pack up and move
to loot New Zealand the answer was no
because the civilization isn't close to
over or the greatest civilization in the
history of mankind no no it was not this
is this is dangerous dangerous stuff by
the way I'll just know the Nancy Pelosi
the same person who last week was
suggesting and ridiculous to say that
she hates the president and that's why
she's impeaching back in 1998 she said
the only reason Republicans were
impeaching was because they hated
President Clinton today the Republican
majority is not judging the present
president with fairness but impeaching
him with a vengeance in the
investigation of the president
fundamental principles which Americans
hold dear privacy fairness checks and
balances have been seriously violated
and why because we are here as we are
here today because the Republicans in
the House are paralyzed with hatred of
President Clinton and until the
Republicans free themselves of this
hatred our country will suffer and it
amazing is the same person who said you
should never use hatred about
impeachment and me I'm a Catholic mm-hmm
okay we'll get to more of this in just
one second and we will get to the added
incendiary factor here of media
malfeasance when it comes to coverage of
our politics because the media just like
that our politics on a routine basis
it's astonishing I'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the best gift that you can get for your
wife your mother your sister come
holiday season I'm talking about pearls
okay these are just like fantastic so I
have gotten pearls for my wife from the
pearl source these pearls are spec to
you you wonder how my wife can stand me
I know everyone does how does dr.
Shapiro stay with you the answer is i
buy her jewelry and the jewelry that i
buy her is jewelry from the pearl source
there is nothing more classic and
timeless than fine pearl jewelry which
doesn't need to break your budget at the
but at the pearl source you get the
highest quality pearl jewelry and up to
70% off retail price Antonis are better
prices than any where you're gonna find
plus I know the people who are on this
place like I've known them for literally
nearly my entire life and the people who
run this place are as honest as the day
is long they're really honest or
high-quality stuff at the best possible
price the pearl source cuts out the
middleman they eliminate traditional
five times markup by jewelry stores they
sell directly to you the consumer if you
need it quickly for the holidays it is
not too late the pearl source offers
free two-day shipping on every order so
you put it off don't worry you still got
a few weeks until Christmas or Hanukkah
or whatever now's the time to do it
because you get that free two-day
shipping everything comes beautifully
packaged in an elegant jewelry box it's
ready to be given as a gift you will
receive your beautiful pearls well
before it is time to give them also the
pearl source comes with a no-hassle 60
day money back guarantee so it is
absolutely risk-free
plus with more than 20 years in the
pearl business and over 5000 five-star
reviews you can be sure that you are
shopping from a trusted retailer again I
have pearl earrings from my wife and
pearl necklace from my wife from the
pearl source
she loves wearing it it's beautiful
stuff it's the only reason I'm still
Mary it's the only reason she can stand
me go check out the pearl source comm
/ban enter promo code Bennett check out
for 20% off your entire order makes a
great gift for wife mom sister daughter
it really and again you handed down
generation to generation beautiful stuff
if you want find pearl jewelry at the
best prices online go straight to the
source the pearl source the pearl source
comm slash been enter promo code been at
checkout I vouch for them I promise
she'll love it go check it out the pearl
source comm /ban enter promo code been
at checkout again it comes to that no
hassle 60 day money-back guarantee
risk-free get two day shipping and you
get 20% off your entire order ProSource
comm slash man enter promo club and it's
great stuff okay so it is it so we have
a few factors that are militating in
favor of heightened conflict right now
in the United States come 2020 mean it
feels like fever-pitch
it does and I will say I think that part
of the reason that Democrats are pushing
the feeling of fever-pitch
is as sort of a tacit thread so if you
reelect Trump there will be people in
the streets this chaos will continue and
it's not just trumpian chaos it's not
just that Trump is crazy man you don't
know what he's gonna do it's we are not
going to allow the country to go back to
a certain level of stasis the fact is
the economy right now is historically
booming like it's as good as it has ever
been in the history of the United States
we are at the lowest unemployment rates
in American history for the last 100
years okay since since 1969 we have not
had unemployment rates this low we have
a booming stock market right it's up
around 28,000 like these are enormous
enormous numbers
we should be pretty happy right things
things are going fairly well we are not
engaged in any massive foreign conflict
yes we have long lasting wars in places
like Afghanistan places like Syria but
those are low-level conflict hit there's
no draft like we're not in the middle of
a massive foreign campaign like things
are actually pretty good and most
Americans walking around the country day
don't feel terrible about the country or
feel bad about themselves but the media
the Democrats they're trying to suggest
that we that civilization itself is at
stake we've had three years of Donald
Trump his civilization been been
completely destroyed by Donald Trump I
don't like a lot of the things the guy
says you don't like a lot of the things
the guy says but the economy is good
we're doin okay on foreign policy the
attempt to heighten the chaos is one of
the things the Democrats in the media
want to do because if you heightened the
cast
then it provides the contrast of a quote
unquote back to normalcy campaign for
the Democrats this is why Joe Biden is
doing well in the general polling it's
also why he's doing well in the primary
polling because most Americans are tired
they are tired of this okay it's why
I've said that I think President Trump
needs to tone it down he doesn't have to
play into it but this is also a
purposeful plan by some people in the
media and many in the media would like
to see this conflict heightened make the
stakes higher because the higher you
make the stakes the more you can get
your voting base out to vote and
convince moderates that all this will
just go away right everything go back to
normal everybody will calm down if Joe
Biden becomes President of the United
States okay so let's get to the media so
we've had over the past few weeks we've
had past few years Democrats claim
fundamental American Institute like key
American institutions need to go because
they're not democratic we have heard
that Republicans are vicious racists who
want to put y'all back in Chains in the
word of Joe Biden about Mitt Romney the
most milquetoast human being who has
ever walked the earth we have heard from
Democrats that they want to get rid of
the Electoral College they want to
rewrite the US Senate they want to stack
the Supreme Court because Republicans
are a threat to everything you hold dear
and every time Republicans win a
presidential election it's illegitimate
and by the way if Donald Trump wins in
2020 it's because he wasn't impeached
and because he is and because he's
militarizing American foreign policy in
order to benefit himself in the 2020
election and on top of that the media
claiming that Republicans are invariably
and always crazy people and the media
covering these things in incredibly
false ways so
let me give you a couple of quick
examples first example is about
president Trump so President Trump over
the weekend speaks at this pro-israel
council the israeli-american council and
he says a couple of things and Democrats
particularly reporters from place like
Vox
or activists from places like Media
Matters they immediately clip these
things out of context in order to
suggest that President Trump is a
vicious anti-semite while he's being
cheered loudly by the American Israel by
the Israeli American Council okay so
Trump for example he was talking over
the weekend about business and he leads
off this part of his speech talking
about how people in the room are
hard-nosed businesspeople
okay this clip is about how people in
them are hard-nosed businesspeople and
here is what he says the real estate
business because I know you very well
your brutal killers not nice people at
all but you have to vote for him yep no
choice you're not gonna vote for
Pocahontas I can tell you that you're
not gonna vote for the wealth tax yeah
let's take a hundred percent of you
wealth away no no even if you don't like
me some of you don't some of you I don't
like it all actually and you're gonna be
my biggest supporters because you'll be
out of business in about 15 minutes if
they get it okay so people in the media
played this as though he was being
anti-semitic in this clip I'm not
kidding you there were people in the
media who suggested that this was an
anti-semitic line because he was saying
to Jews that that some of them are not
nice people
he's explicitly talking about people he
did real estate with the entire clip is
about hide 2 deals with you guys you
guys hate me I hate you you're gonna
vote for me anyway because at least I'm
not a crazed socialist the media played
this as though Donald Trump was being an
anti-semite in that clip hey that is why
that's incredibly dishonest incredibly
dishonest okay and then Trump talks
about Israel and he is that the Israeli
American Council okay so these are
people care deeply about Israel and he
makes a point okay as usual not always
in the best way but what he says here is
not actually wrong here as president and
again they tried to proclaim that this
is anthe semantics here's President
Trump saying that he is very pro-israel
and Jews should be more pro-israel now
as I've said before if what he means by
that is that people with the last name
Berg and steen ought to be more
pro-israel than that's silly because
there are a lot of people who are born
Jewish you don't give a damn about
Israel but if he means
people who actually care about Judaism
people who consider themselves Jews for
purposes of public discussion then he is
correct there are many Jews who do not
care enough about Israel many many Jews
who do not care enough about Israel who
care more about abortion until ninth
month and same-sex marriage than they do
about Israel which if you have any
semblance of understanding of Judaism is
kind of ridiculous Trump is not wrong in
what he says here the media portrayed
this is anti-semitic we have to get the
people of our country of this country to
love Israel more I have to tell you that
we have to do it we have to get them to
love Israel more because you have people
that are Jewish people that are great
people they don't love Israel enough you
know that ok nothing he says there is
wrong the media played this as though
this is an emetic he's literally saying
that people should be more Pro the
Jewish state and also there are lots of
Jews who don't care enough about the
Jewish state a hundred percent true ok
but we're going to pretend that that is
him being virulent ly anti-semitic from
the same party that voted in the last
week that Jews settling in historic
Jewish areas is a violation of
international law
and for members of the House Democratic
Party decided they would not vote even
for that condemnation of Trump because
it would suggest a two-state solution
rashida to leave was a blatant
anti-semite from Michigan she suggested
then when it comes to Israel there
should not be a Jewish state she said
there should not be a two-state solution
ok understand a two-state solution
according to Rasheeda Talib would be a
Palestinian state in his real stand as
an insurer state she doesn't want that
she wants it to go away
she says that would be an apartheid
state so she wants the destruction of
the Jewish state no commentary from the
media none nobody even asked a question
about it but Trump is very divisive on
Israel the Democrat the media there are
their attempts to play up the the
radicalism of the Republicans is quite
insane and completely complete and and
downplay by the way the radicalism of
the Democratic Party is completely
completely dishonest incredibly
dishonest I'll give you another example
of that in just one second first let's
talk about how you make your home look
better so how can you accomplish this
well way number one is that you can
ensure that your window coverings look
good I know you haven't thought about
your window coverings did you did you
you go to your paint job go to your
floor you look at the window coverings
because frankly who does well now you're
looking at them they're ugly okay
don't don't turn away they're ugly you
need blinds.com you need to make those
window coverings better with blinds calm
you get a free online design
consultation you just send them pictures
of your house and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme up
furniture and specific rooms here's the
best part
if you accidentally miss measure or you
pick the wrong color if you make a
mistake
blinds comm will remake your blinds for
free they've made it really easy for you
there's no excuse to leave up those
mangled blinds that make your place look
like a set from the wire for a limited
time get 20% off everything at blinds
comm when you use promo code bet I mean
their stuff is beautiful and again you
screw it up
they make it right that's a pretty great
deal blinds kaam promo club n for 20%
off everything faux wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades and more blinds
calm promo code Ben go check them out
right now upgrade the look and feel of
your home it's a really easy way to do
it won't cost you a fortune in you get
20% of everything right now and use my
promo code go-to blinds calm and use
promo code then go check that out right
now
ok we'll get you more of this plus we'll
get to the Democratic presidential race
we'll get to this terrorist attack that
happened in Florida get to all of that
in just a minute but if you're not
already subscribe or you are really
missing out head on over to tell you
where to come / subscribe do it now oh
wait we'll just wait here together until
you do it for as little as ten bucks a
month you get our articles to add free
access to all of our live broadcasts our
full show library select bonus content
our exclusive daily wire app which is a
pretty great feature if you haven't
checked it out yet if you choose the new
All Access plan you get all of that plus
the legendary leftist ears tumbler band
our brand-new ask me anything a style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis so stop
depriving yourself come join the fun I
mean like literally tens and tens and
tens of thousands of people who are
members you should help us out too by
becoming a member we really appreciate
this right the leftist year's hot or
cold tumbler which everybody wants
everybody makes a great Christmas
present makes julienne fries I go check
it out right now alright we're back in
just one second i'm ben shapiro this is
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
the media are not content with lying
about Trump they're also lying about
nikki Haley so nikki Haley did an
interview with the former ambassador to
the UN former South Carolina Governor
remember when she was governor of South
Carolina while she was governor there's
a mass shooting at a Charleston Church
by a brutal terrorist racist white
supremacist racist and then there was a
picture of that guy holding a
confederate flag and nikki Haley as the
governor of the state had the
Confederate flag battle flag removed
from state grounds and put in a museum
and she made a speech about it at the
time talking about the the conflicted
history of the competitive flag how many
people saw it as a symbol of bravery and
and home and hearth and how many people
saw it as a symbol of racism which of
course it originally was right and how
that morphed over time for many people
it didn't have its original relation to
slavery but you saw how it was divisive
and she saw how it hurt people and all
of this yes the shoes on Glenn Beck and
she was asked about the Confederate flag
controversy and here is what she said
and the ability of the media to take
perfectly innocuous statements out of
context and use it to call people like
nikki Haley racist remember she's the
person who took it off state grounds in
South Carolina in 2015 and made a speech
about the history of the Confederate
flag she made a statement about it about
how she totally understood why when
black Americans looked at that flag they
saw effectively speaking a swastika
right she she got that okay but she also
understood that the vast majority people
who had a confederate flag bumper
sticker on the back of their car were
not Nazis and we're not white
supremacist all of which is true right
all of those things can be true at the
same time they suggested over the
weekend the nikki Haley was actually a
racist who is making excuses for the
original confederate flag and pretending
that it didn't have any link to historic
racism they did it based on taking her
out of context on on Glenn Beck's show
here is this guy that comes out with his
manifesto holding the Confederate flag
and had just hijacked everything that
people thought of it we don't have
hateful people in South Carolina there's
always a small minority that's always
going to be there but you people saw it
as service and sacrifice and heritage
and but once he did that there were
there was no way to overcome it and the
national media came in
in droves they wanted to define what
happened they wanted to make this about
racism they wanted to make it about gun
control they wanted to make it about
death penalty okay so she says that and
they say oh well that means that she
thinks that the Confederate flag doesn't
have any history of relation to racism
that's what she thinks okay she no no in
2015 she specifically made statements
about exactly what these what exactly
the Confederate flag was when she gave
his statements June 2015
right a televised statement and she
talked about the people of South
Carolina and she talked about the she
talked about the Confederate flag and
she said in that speech on matters of
race South Carolina has a tough history
we all know that many of us have seen it
in our own lives and lives our parents
and grandparents we don't need reminders
in spite of last week's tragedy we've
come a long way since those days and
have much to be proud of but there's
more we can do that brings me to the
subject of the Confederate flag that
flies on the Statehouse grounds for many
people in our state the flag stands for
traditions that our noble traditions of
history of heritage and of ancestry the
hate-filled murderer who massacred our
brothers and sisters in Charleston has a
sick and twisted view of the flag in no
way does he reflect the people in our
state who respected in many ways Revere
it those South Carolinians view the flag
is a symbol of respect integrity and
duty they also see at his memorial a way
to honor ancestors that is not hate
nortis nor is it racism at the same time
it is what said in 2015 when she removed
the flag from state grounds at the same
time for many others in South Carolina
the flag is a deeply offensive symbol of
a brutally oppressive past as a state we
can survive as we have done while still
being home to both of those viewpoints
we do not need to declare a winner and a
loser here we respect freedom of
expression and that for those who wish
to show the respect for the flag on
their private property no one will stand
in your way but the Statehouse is
different and events of the past week
call upon us to look at this in a
different way
15 years ago after much contentious
debate South Carolina came together in a
bipartisan way to move the flag from
atop the Capitol dome today we are here
in a moment of unity in our state
without a will to say it's time to move
the flag from Capitol grounds and now
they're trying to paint nikki Haley as a
brutal racist now they're trying to
paint nikki Haley who moved the flag as
a brutal racist hey this is part of a
broader agenda to suggest that the
Republican Party utterly and completely
is radical and trying to tear apart the
country and is dangerous to the country
and also think when elections the
elections are illegitimate there
steal elections this is why you hear
Democrats talk about voter suppression
there is no evidence of widespread voter
suppression in the United States none
okay the evidence that Republicans are
attempting to quote-unquote suppress the
vote and keep people from being able to
vote based on voter ID was is absurd the
idea that you want to make sure that
somebody is voting who says they're
voting by having them show an ID that is
not voter suppression poll taxes are
voter suppression pull tests those are
voter suppression
okay constitutionally speaking it is not
voter suppression to suggest that
polling places have to be open for
widespread hours not at specific hours
of the day it is not voter suppression
when in Georgia the case where Democrats
keep saying there was voter suppression
black turnout has outpaced black share
of the population in Georgia for years
including in the stacey abrams race hey
that's not voter suppression but
Democrats keep claiming this stuff so
they can claim that every election is a
legitimate and then get people like
Charles blow again awful columnist for
The New York Times with a piece called
own Nicki you're so wrong there's much
nikki Haley could learn from a true
heroine of the South Carolina
Confederate flag removal Bree Newsome
Bassin he has a long column about how
nikki Haley about nikki Haley doesn't
understand the history of the
Confederate flag just she gave an
astonishing statement for the very
brazenness of its erasure of history and
it's bowing to a racist narrative any
image of morality and unity Haley had
cultivated vanished when those words
left her lips she did not say my view of
the Confederate flag is that the
Confederate flag only represents heroism
and decency that's not what she said she
said the vast majority of South
Carolinians who fly the flag it doesn't
represent being a fan of Jim Crow or
racism which is true how is it how do we
know that's true because of five minutes
ago Democrats were saying the same thing
Joe Biden praised a group that displayed
the Confederate flag as fine people like
three years ago four years ago Howard
Dean famously invoked the Confederate
flag in his 2004 race here is Joe Biden
is just a few years ago talking about
the fine people who displayed the
Confederate flag moving in eloquent
speech as a son of the Confederacy
acknowledging that it was time to change
in yield to a position that Senator
carol moseley-braun raised on the floor
of the Senate not granting a federal
Charter to a organization made up of
many fine people who continue to display
the Confederate flag
okay so again many find people who
displayed the Confederate flag Howard
Dean did the same thing back in 2004 and
he said that he wanted to be the he want
to be the candidate for Democrats who
flew a confederate flag on their bumper
sticker rather this was acceptable until
five seconds ago nikki Haley says it
it's no longer acceptable because
everyone apparently who has a
confederate flag on their bumper sticker
is a racist which is a hell of a way to
win elections in the south of you're a
Democrat really to call everyone who
flies who has a confederate flag a
vicious racist like the dukes of hazzard
are now vicious racists okay good luck
with this here's Howard Dean back when
the Democrats were slightly less insane
without the south I'm going to go to the
south and I'm going to say to white guys
who drive pickup trucks with Confederate
flag details in the back decals in the
back of their car we want your vote too
because your hell kids don't have health
insurance either okay when Democrats
headed it was fine when Republicans say
it apparently it is truly truly awful
meanwhile if you're a Democrat you can
say pretty much anything in the media
will let you get away with it so a Oh
see the illustrious aoc shoot the
brilliant AOC she tweeted out that
Amazon is coming to New York Amazon is
coming to New York they agreed to open
in Hudson Yards they didn't get any
financial incentives from New York City
or state she tweeted out a picture of
herself like sitting in the lounge of
her upscale Washington DC apartment
building she tweeted won't you look at
that Amazon is coming to New York City
anyway without requiring the public to
finance shady deals helipad handouts for
Jeff Bezos and corporate giveaways
maybe the Trump administration should
focus more on cutting public assistance
to billionaires instead of poor families
again she doesn't even understand
Trump's food stamp policy the food stamp
policy that has work requirements does
not apply to families with children it
only applies to single people who are
not were
King cuz she does like again she's
mischaracterizing this stuff again she's
mischaracterizing this stuff but also
it's worth noting that the twenty five
thousand Amazon jobs that were supposed
to come to New York they were supposed
to come to her district now fifteen
hundred jobs are coming to New York
outside her district she's an idiot okay
and she's always been an idiot she
doesn't know the hell she's talking
about but the media are gonna continue
to treat her as though she is she's
worth talking about okay so what is all
of this designed to do all of this is
designed to create a feeling of chaos
and the feeling of gas can only be
alleviated only be alleviated if you
give Democrats what they want
it can only be alleviated if you give
Democrats what they want now the most
extreme version of this sort of politics
is practiced you know decades ago by
Marion Barry in Washington DC is not a
racial thing Marion Barry absolutely
said that he would create unrest in the
streets unless his constituents were
given what they wanted and there's
there's a very good book on this and
name of it escapes me but I mentioned it
in the past on the show talking about
how America's major cities were riven by
chaos specifically designed to create
government policy from the inside
there's sort of this inside outside game
you see at on college campuses a lot
where there'll be chaos when a speaker
comes to campus and the administration
instead of cracking down on people who
are committing the chaos the
administration just caves to the chaos
and says okay I guess we'll alleviate
your woes we'll give you what you want
hey Democrats in the media are now doing
the same thing it's chaos out there it's
craziness now a lot of that is being
pushed by the Democrats in the media
that it's chaos and craziness out there
because again walk outside today are you
seeing a zombie apocalypse
I'm not when you're not watching the
news when you turn off Twitter do you
really feel as though the country is in
a state of vast chaos complete breakdown
when you turn off and that by the way is
not just left wingers when you turn off
Fox when you turn off my show when you
drop any of the when you don't follow
politics for five seconds
does it feel like cancer does it feel
like things are kind of okay it feels
like things are kinda okay but for a lot
of members of the Democratic media the
goal is to create this feeling of chaos
so that you're gonna go okay fine just
put old Joe in there
honestly like old you just do old Joe
cuz old Joe I mean like guys not even
alive just put him in there speaking of
Joe Biden right Joe by a corpse Joe
Biden walking the earth he has proof
that there is
life and it's not just government
programs it's also if you're a senator
from Delaware who never stops running
for president so Joe Biden Joe Biden
over the weekend he made the little
admission that he should put
restrictions on hunter this is kind of
hilarious he's been saying the whole
time that hunter never didn't he never
did anything wrong with regard to hunter
but now he's like I suppose we should
put some restrictions on hunter like not
allowing him to trot around the globe
picking up bags of cash because his last
name is the same as mine
here is Joe Biden now reversing course
so you're elected you're in office what
guardrails would you have to be sure
that your son your brother Jimmy doesn't
do anything to trade on the family name
they will not be engaged in any foreign
business because of what's happened in
this administration no one's going to be
seeking patents for things from China no
one's gonna be engaged in that kind of
thing so no foreign business for correct
relatives because it happened in this
administration not because the questions
about him and his son no that's just cuz
of Trump it's cuz of Trump it's all cuz
of Trump by the way that was not the
only gap that Joe Biden made about his
son over the weekend who's interviewed
by NPR and he said no nobody even nobody
even raised the issue to me okay we know
in open testimony george kent said that
he went to Vice President Biden's team
and they said we didn't have time for
this so it turns out that wasn't true
here's Joe Biden saying an untrue thing
but there were former White House aides
of yours who tried to warn you about the
potential conflicts of interests nobody
warned me about excessive conflict of
interest nobody warned me about that and
at the same time George Kent the State
Department official testified but he
raised it to you no he did not
you're sad I never had ever heard that
once two year staff and their staff told
him he has no punt width oh my son I
guess that's why he said it because my
son was on his deathbed but that that
not the reason why they should have told
me okay so now he's saying they should
have told them but the reason they said
they didn't tell him is because they
were afraid he's gonna blow up but if
they did tell him so so Joe Biden is
certainly not any representative of
institutional stability or personal
stability as it turns out and by the way
he's a radical - he's revised himself on
his own positions that used to be
moderated he came out over the weekend
and again suggested we have to dump the
hide
which means federal funding for direct
abortion I came out a while ago saying
we have to get rid of the Hyde Amendment
because there's no longer you doable and
usable and no longer a serious option
for anybody all that you have all these
states going out and not only
challenging whether or not there's a
there saying that it's a criminal
offense and you're going back to the
grant I hear let me be the best way to
say it if I get like the president on
stays in the supreme court overrules
Rovi way and I'm going to send
legislation to the United States
Congress to pass it and cut and codify
it okay so the media's play here is put
that doddering old nut in the White
House because you put that doddering old
mutt in the White House then everyone
will feel more stable do you feel more
stable look at that guy do things feel
more stable the only way they feel more
stable is have Trump keep saying crazy
things it's why Trump should stop saying
crazy things but does that seem like a
beacon of stability to you maybe
Elizabeth Warren seems like a beacon of
stability to you again the play of the
media here is make things feel like the
house is on fire
and that the arsonists will come in and
put out the fire if and only if you pay
the ransom I'd say that but does
Elizabeth Warren feel I could be kind of
stay but ability by the way it was
really funny over the weekend Elizabeth
Warren finally admitted she shouldn't
have called herself Native American
publicly so this only took forever
I do appreciate her blue sweater today
she has this rotated we've been noticing
this she has a rotating series of
sweaters every single that this very
weird kind of 1970s teach and outfit
that you are used to wear this at
Harvard Law School to be fair so she's
dead this is nothing new here is
Elizabeth Warren in a blue sweater which
she's changing it up today talking about
how she shouldn't have called herself a
Native American which is weird she did
so for decades - the cheers of the
actors of the academic left I shouldn't
have done it I am NOT a person of color
I am NOT a citizen of a tribe and I have
apologized for confusion I've caused on
trial citizenship tribal sovereignty and
for any harm that I caused weird how
every Republican complained about Joe
Biden and hunter Biden has now been half
legitimated by Joe Biden saying he's
gonna read you the the restrictions when
he becomes president and every complaint
about Elizabeth Warren being focus on
tests those have been legitimized by now
her
backing backing off but for years we
were told that you're not allowed to ask
about hunter Biden we're still being
told that and we were told that it's
racist super to note that Elizabeth
Warren is actually not Native American
because stability guys that's what we
need stability and I trust our media to
establish that that baseline level of
stability by the way these are the same
Democrats who are claiming again that
Donald Trump is responsible for every
evil thing Hillary Clinton suggesting
that Trump is inciting mass shootings at
synagogues and churches and Walmart here
is Hillary Clinton who is definitely
definitely not campaigning for president
saying that chaos has broken out because
if Trump by the way there were shootings
in synagogues before Trump was president
there was shooting at the Charleston
Church shooting was in 2015
Barack Obama was president at that time
and but here is Hillary Clinton
suggesting that it's only all chaos is
due to trump clearly he he just incites
these these deep irrational and
unfortunately sometimes violent emotions
some of the people who have gone into
synagogues and in churches and Walmart's
and other places and shot them up and
murdered people have clearly been
unleashed I don't want to say it's a
direct cause I don't think that's fair
but people are amped up people are amped
up people yes people want people as
opposed to if you just elect an old
stodgy joe biden everything will be
better okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like the Democratic Party
has claimed for years that the Great
Society helped the country in
innumerable ways now the Great Society
really it was the Civil Rights Act the
Voting Rights Act right those were good
pieces of legislation with the exception
that I've always said that the Civil
Rights Act should not have been applied
to private businesses that the direct
impact of the Civil Rights Act should
have come down on state governments that
were imposing Jim Crow from above now if
you have to vote for the entire thing or
not the entire thing you vote for the
entire thing because more important to
stop Jim Crow then even to protect
private property rights at the time but
with that said the rest of the Great
Society programs were a dud not only
were they had done they were a deeply
damaging to that that achieved precisely
the opposite of what they intended to
achieve in quashing poverty the rates of
poverty basically continued to decline
at the same rates they were declining
before the Great Society programs except
now we were spending 20 trillion dollars
on it a Medici Lai's is a great new
about this she's a terrific author she's
the author of the book The Forgotten man
all about the failures of the New Deal
she has a great book about it's called
great society a new history
she really yo points out sort of the
leadership in this movement Walter
Reuther comes in for some serious crisis
in the former head of the United Auto
Workers the book is is really well
written is worthy of the read Great
Society a new history go check it out by
a Matisse lays for everybody who
suggests the Democrats healed America
with the Great Society programs no no
they they really did not they led to
decades of economic stagnation through
through the Great Society programs and
we are still bearing the legacy of those
in the massive national debt that we
carry okay time for a quick thing that I
hate so there's a performance artist and
he taped a banana to a wall it sold for
one hundred and twenty thousand dollars
and Miami's Art Basel Festival this week
if you want to say that we are in the
final stages of a civilization this
would probably be a good indicator it's
a contemporary art piece titled the
comedian and again it's sold for a
staggering 120 thousand dollars it is
now in a different artists stomach
according to reports the comedian was an
installation meant ostensibly to make
fun of the art world's obsession with
banal and uninspired works according to
its creator Maurizio Cattelan
but most viewers saw it is simply a
rotting banana duct-taped to a wall
daily wires a man depressed jacquimo
reported earlier this week that the
piece presented in our Basel the
American version of the avant-garde
Swiss art Showcase is one of three
similar pieces showcased around the
world and the artists Catalan prides
himself on mocking the rest of
contemporary art with his work aji the
banana is a follow-up to his 2017
installation a golden toilet that sold
for six million dollars but is currently
missing after a shocking art heist that
took place in the UK earlier this year
apparently the golden toilet is now
installed at the Pentagon on Saturday
another contemporary artist decided to
make his own show of the duct tape
banana he peeled the fruit off the wall
and consumed it in front of a crowd of
horrified onlookers
here's what this looks like he just goes
right for it he peels it off the wall
and and eats the banana hung he calls it
hungry artist it took some work for this
guy to find the banana it was removed
from public display after Art Basel
concluded earlier this week and
relocated to a gallery the tuna was also
given incredible leeway for the stunt he
actually conversed with several patrons
who are treating his efforts with utter
seriousness because this was in fact a
work of art Catalan worked on his art
for a year according to the press
release from the gallery where Catalans
banana was being exhibited for sale the
gallery claims it has sentimental value
to the artist apparently the good news
is that it's easy to replace the banana
shocking you can get it for under a
dollar anywhere in the United States so
don't worry it's art though it's
definitely definitely art it's not the
decline of art it's not that a client of
Western civilization it's not the fact
that we have too much money apparently
being held by it like you want to turn
turn means well Bernie Sanders socialist
tell me someone paid 120 thousand
dollars for a banana taped to a duct
wall a duct taped to a wall that would
be the answer right there is solid stuff
there yeah the death of art definitely
has taken place in real time which is
why you go to a modern art museum you're
like oh my kid could paint that right
your kid could paint that this is
correct because art has been completely
separated from school it's the message
of the art that matters the message and
once the art becomes about the message
and not about the actual art the art is
supposed to be universal in the sense
that it's supposed to have meaning for
everyone who takes a look at this you
know what this means this duct-tape
banana to a wall it means that
everyone's a so I guess that
achieves that effect and sheaves that
purpose the art critic by the way over
at the New York Times defended this
thing and said no no it is indeed art a
grudging defense of the one hundred and
twenty thousand dollar banana
Jason farrago says art may be long in
life short but the existence of a hand
fruit is most ephemeral ephemeral of all
this week at Art Basel Miami Beach the
art world's premier champagne steep swap
meet no work for more grins guffaws and
selfies than a new sculpture I call it a
sculpture by the semi-retired italian
trickster Maurizio Cattelan a banana
duct-taped to a wall its peel already
speckled with brown spots it's titled
comedian by Wednesday it already won art
wheel nor art world notoriety on
Saturday achieved
public visibility that any artist would
envy after a self-promoting wag tore the
banana off the wall and gobbles it up
suffice it to say that works of
Contemporary Art rarely make the cover
of the New York Post but this is mr.
Catalans the second recent appearance on
the tabloids front page when it comes to
the bananas ontological status is art or
protist I thought we had settled this
already if you buy a light work by Dan
Flavin and the fluorescent bulb starts
flickering you can replace it with a new
one if you buy a Sol to wit wall drawing
and you move my house you can erase the
old one and draw a new one
a banana even more than a light fixture
was always going to require replacement
Catalan had already drawn up
instructions for the lucky collectors to
replace the fruit every day to ten days
as to why Catalans banana has grouped
the public imagination has something to
do with the price something to do also
with the comic potential of bananas is
it art did you have to be there let me
reassure you you are not a hopeless
Philistine if you find this all a bit
foolish foolishness and a deflating
sense that a culture that once
encouraged the blind beauty now only
permits dopey jokes is mr. Catalans
stock-in-trade
but perhaps we'll find more to
appreciate in Catalans work if you take
notes of two points one formal one
social says the New York Times art
critic first I've been just made to
discover that for a work that has been
endlessly photographed and parodied over
the course of its one week life almost
no one has discussed that it is not just
a banana
it is a banana and a piece of duct tape
and this is a significant difference
comedian is not a one-note Dada as Tim
posture in which commodity is proclaimed
a work of art which would be an entire
century and update now as dated as a
film director mimicking DW Griffith
comedian is a sculpture one that
continues mr. Catalans decades-long
reliance on suspension to make the
obvious seem ridiculous and to deflate
and defeat the pretensions of earlier ok
fire this guy fire this guy seriously
fire the critic fire the artist fire
everyone the culture that produced the
Sistine Chapel has now produced a man
duct-taping a banana to a wall the
culture that produced Bach Beethoven and
Brahms has now produced a piece of fruit
that is rotting on a wall taped out with
duct tape and we are supposed to believe
that this is a deep this is a deep and
profound commentary on American culture
the only commentary on American culture
is that anybody took this thing
seriously in the first place it's
ridiculous on its face and the fact that
nobody aspires anymore instead we just
find joy in mockery
then nobody aspires anymore maybe that's
the only thing
has to say about her culture made that
was Catalans point in ain't worth 120
grand I just gave it to you for free so
enjoy already we'll be back here later
za with two additional hours of content
we have a lot to get to a little bit
later today so definitely tune in or
show up here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by micro Mina hair and makeup is by Jess
wa al Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wired production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 politics is downstream of culture
but politics effects culture too as a
banana duct tape tool wall sells for
$120,000 at Art Basel as drag queen
story our hits preschools and as kids
get hooked on hardcore porn before the
age of 10 libertarians be where we
examine whether politics can help us fix
our screwed up culture check it out on
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]